the scale on a map is seven centimeters
for every 10 kilometers or seven kilo
centimeters per 10 kilometers
if the distance between the two cities
is 60 kilometers so that's the actual
distance how far apart in centimeters
are the two cities on the map well they
give us the scale
for every 10 kilometers in the real
world the map is going to show seven
seven centimeters or another way to
think about it is if you see seven
centimeters on the map that represents
10 kilometers in the real world
now they're saying that the distance
between two cities is 60 kilometers
kilometers so it's essentially six times
it's essentially six times ten
kilometers so times six
so if you have six times ten kilometers
on the map you're going to have six
times seven centimeters so times six and
six times seven centimeters gets you to
centimeters so how far apart in
centimeters are the two cities on the
map well 42
centimeters